[Music]
[Applause]
they say home is where the heart is
that is until you're told you can't
leave then it might feel more like a
prison now imagine the entire population
of the United States having to stay home
in a lockdown that's over three hundred
and thirty million people but what does
a lockdown actually mean why would the
u.s. go under lockdown and how would it
affect you this is what if and here's
what would happen if the US were under
lockdown a lockdown would have huge
ramifications on the economy and
everyday life of Americans job loss
recession and an increase in anxiety and
depression are all consequences of a
lockdown so what would push the u.s. to
such a major step and what would that
look like an international pandemic is
probably the only thing that would force
the u.s. into lockdown why well in the
case of a highly contagious virus
scientists and health experts urge
social isolation and self quarantine as
the best and most important ways to stop
the spread of disease a key part of this
to isolate healthy people too but seeing
as healthy people might be less likely
to volunteer self-isolation the
government might decide to step in and
mandate that people don't leave their
home except for essential activities
what are essential activities well take
grocery shopping and essential jobs like
medical staff or garbage collection as
examples and don't forget truck drivers
they're the backbone of the food supply
chain America has already been facing a
shortage of truck drivers since 2018 and
could face even more shortages with the
viral pandemic
but what about farmers luckily because
farming happens in rural areas experts
don't think there will be too much
disruption to agriculture but with the
combination of panic Buy and a shortage
of truck drivers grocery stores can find
it difficult to keep their shelves
stocked other than these essential jobs
and going to grocery stores you're
pretty much stuck at home no going to
school no going out to restaurants or
bars no retail shopping no group
gatherings if you're lucky you could
still work from home this would offer
some sort of routine and distraction
throughout the day as well as necessary
income if you're in an industry such as
travel food services or brick-and-mortar
retail then you're not so lucky you
would lose your income for an undefined
amount of time loss of income for many
people puts them at risk of losing the
roof over their head 18 million people
in the US spend over 50 percent or more
of their income on rent or mortgage to
help ease this burden states may put
holds on evictions and foreclosures
during a lockdown this happened during
the 2020 pandemic loss of income also
affects the economy as a whole and can
cause panic in the financial markets on
March 16th 2020 the Dow plunged nearly
3,000 points this was one of the largest
point drops in America's history and
happened as every day life came to a
grinding halt
amid an international pandemic the
airline industry alone sought a 50
billion dollar bailout in 2020 with an
estimated loss of 63 to 113 billion
dollars globally according to the Bureau
of Labor Statistics only about one third
of the u.s. is able to work from home it
can be difficult to work from home if
you're not used to it especially if your
spouse and kids are home with you
not to mention the feelings of anxiety
and depression which are common with
isolation and uncertainty these feelings
can make it very difficult to focus on
your work it gets more difficult if you
have kids not only do you have to get
some work done during the day but you
also have to homeschool your kids and
provide entertainment for them apart
from the boredom of staying at home why
would a lockdown cause anxiety and
depression well humans are social beings
even if you enjoy solitude which is
different from isolation physical touch
is still a very important form of
communication one you might not know you
miss until you don't have it anymore
in a study performed after the 2003 SARS
outbreak individuals who were
quarantined often had high levels of
psychological distress this was not just
from isolation but also a feeling of
uncertainty from a lack of clear or
reliable information a nationwide
lockdown of more than 330 million people
would have huge mental and economic
consequences but is it the best way to
stop a virus pandemic well it does slow
it down
we know that slowing the spread of a
disease means that hospitals will be
better equipped to handle patients
urgent needs and save lives but a
mandatory geographic quarantine is the
most severe form of a lockdown and would
probably be seen as unconstitutional in
the u.s. instead the US federal
government typically provides support
funding and expert opinions while
leaving city and state officials to
decide on specific measures closing
schools banning bars and restaurants
canceling all events and urging people
to work from home were all mandates that
happened during the pandemic in 2020 in
times of pandemics and lockdowns
we have to remember our individual
actions and decisions really do matter
and make a difference most important we
are all part of a community and we need
to unite together even if we can't
physically be together
one thing you definitely don't need to
do is hoard all the toilet paper but
that's a story for another what if
[Music]
you